في نهايه الاسبوع اخترنا الامير هاري
شخصيه هذا الاسبوع او شخصيه اسبوع صباح
العربيه ومع هذه التطورات في قضيه هي اصبح
اول ملكي بريطانيا رفيع المستوى يمثل امام
المحكمه في منصه شهود منذ
132 عاما على مدار اليومين السابقين ادلى
ذوق بشهادته في دعواه ضد الصحافه الحقيره
على حد وصفه هذه يتهم المجموعه المالكه
لصحيفه ميرور بتدمير فتره مراهقته
وعلاقاته الشخصيه بل كانت السبب الاساسي
وراء نوبات اكتئابه واصابته بجنون
الارتياب وفق قوله
طبعا من
1996 و 2010 يعتقد هاري انها تضمنت
معلومات جمعت بطريقه غير قانونيه من ضمنها
اختراق هاتفه الشخصي لكن المحكمه تنظر في
33 مقالا فقط حاليا تجري او تجرى المحاكمه
منذ مايو الماضي ومن المتوقع ان تستمر
لسبعه اسابيع فهل الامير هاري تحيه
للصحافه ام هو من استفزها بافعاله الامير
هاري شخصيه اسبوع صباح العربيه نحللها
يتعامل طبعا الامير هاري مع دعواه ضد
الصحف التابلود او الصحافه الصفراء
البريطانيه بمنتهى الجديه ويعتبرها معركته
الرئيسيه دعوه المرور التي
جلساتها حاليا اقامها في عام 2019 وهي
واحده من اربع دعاوى قضائيه اخرى رفعها ضد
صحف مختلفه
برسائل البريد الصوتي اللي كانت تختفي قبل
ان يستمع اليها وكان يعتقد انها مجرد
اعتقني بالفعل تناولت شهاده هاري كيف
تسببت الصحافه في جعله اضحوكه المدرسه بعد
نشرها شخصيه
بداء التقبيل او تشخيصه بداء التقدير تحدث
هاري عن تسريب اتصالات هاتفيه بينه وبين
حبيبته السابقه تشيلسي بالتفاصيل الدقيقه
معا فقدان الثقه مع شقيق الاكبر طبعا
المجموعه المالكه لمرر مشاهدينا دفعت
سابقا مليون جنيه استرليني كتسويات
لضحاياها بعد اثبات مسؤوليتها عن القرصنه
الهاتفيه حاليا تخصص 50 مليون اخرى لتسويه
الاتهامات المستقبليه بما في ذلك قضيه
الامير هاري سابق
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات